the presidential race here in nevada has
only about a 22
000 vote difference between those two
candidates and today the election
department dropping
two more batches of results joe moeller
is there live tonight where a protest is
also underway joe
well the voting is continuing this
evening it's very active outside the
election center here like you mentioned
there is a rally happening
you might be able to hear the horns and
the people up on the sidewalk but then
also
some votes are still being verified take
a look behind here live look here
outside the election center there's
about eight people still here this line
had hundreds throughout the day people
trying to get in there and get their
ballots verified they need to get their
id's double checked
and they just want to get some errors
fixed to make sure that vote is actually
counted
now today we learned only 31 thousand
votes were counted yesterday in clark
county
in today's 4pm update we learned 8 000
more were counted
in clark county there were roughly 115
thousand votes remaining to be counted
which is a bulk of the remaining ones in
the state
those are provisional ballots and mail
ballots the number being counted a day
changed due to some confusion within the
elections department
they expect to have most of those mail
ballots by this sunday
we did catch up with a few people who
were out here in this line to make sure
they're getting their vote counted he
actually had somebody come to the door
yesterday saying that they don't know if
his vote was counted yet
so we went on the website and both seen
that it was under provisional
provisional ballot and to come
up here basically and check to make sure
that our vote
was in
[Music]
last night hundreds of people showed up
to a stop the steel
rally outside the election center the
registrar of voters says there are 300
people who are working inside to get all
these voted
votes counted that is and he says it is
a complex process with several steps
well now the elections department has
stepped up security in the area to keep
those
employees safe now back out here live
you're taking a live look
on the corner here of trade in cheyenne
you can see
that there's dozens of people actually
out there with trump flags they have
trump signs as well many people coming
out here just here at six o'clock this
is supposed to start
there was hundreds out here yesterday
but joe gloria the registrar of
voters here says some of the employees
were concerned about their safety so
they are taking this very seriously
every day because they were out here
last night as well but the next update
we are expecting as far as these results
go
will be tomorrow morning at 10 o'clock
reporting live in north las vegas joe
mohler
8 news now